14 protesters have been killed in Peru
in the latest demonstrations demanding
new elections and the resignation of
President Dina boloati
they died in confrontations with
security forces as they tried to overrun
an airport in the southern city of
juliaka palawati took office after the
impeachment and arrest of former
president Pedro Castillo last month on
charges of rebellion and conspiracy with
Mariana Sanchez joins us live now from
Peru's Capital Lima Mariana so yet more
deaths as these protests continue what's
the latest situation on the ground now
then
that's right Darren 14 uh people dead
among them a 17 year old girl and
according to the ombudsman's office
there are about 38 people wounded some
of them are in critical condition uh now
as you were saying protesters clashed
with police some of the protesters with
makeshift guns and police apparently
firing with live rounds most of the uh
people that have been killed apparently
according to the governor of puno people
that have been shot in the chest and in
the head now uh
many of the protests of the dead of the
deaths happened when uh protesters were
trying to overrun the airport this has
been in fact the deadliest day after a
couple of weeks ago the Army opened fire
in
ayakucho that's another region in the
south of the country where uh the
military killed uh
10 people then now this happened in the
area of funa which is south of the
country the city of huliaka being the
place where the airport is and uh
hundreds and of people coming from
different places in the region of puno
went uh to uh to join in the March uh
because people were very angry at the
government they say that the government
is trying to portray the protests as
illegitimate and also people have been
very angry because they've been sharing
uh uh pictures or a video of social in
social media of a group of policemen
that were destroying a motor motorcycle
taxi which is used by poor people in
Peru to uh to move around to travel and
so people were very angry at this and
they are also very angry because they
say the government has responded by
sending military planes and so on to the
area of funo so the situation is dire in
many provinces there are about 25
provinces that are now on strike and 45
Main roadblock roads have been blocked
in uh in in that region Darren all right
Mariana Sanchez live us there in Lima
Mariana thank you let's bring in uh from
Washington D.C Joe Marie Bert she's an
associate professor of political science
at George Mason University and an expert
on Peruvian politics uh Joe Murray good
to have you with us so 14 more people
have been killed in these
anti-government protests How concerned
are you about the rising number of
protesters being killed and is this also
turning do you think into a human rights
crisis as well as a political one
oh absolutely it is a human rights
rights crisis of uh an increasingly High
degree
um as your reporter mentioned today was
the worst day of violence in just under
one month of Dina boluarte's government
over 40 civilians have been killed in
the context of protests the majority as
the result of security forces firearms
in other words they're being shot at by
police and soldiers
um hundreds have been wounded
um in the context of these protests as
well there's a clear excessive use of
force by security forces and I uh
International organizations
um around the world have called upon the
boluarte government to Cease the
repression and to seek dialogue okay to
peruse current political crisis yeah
that's an important point you make
because I was going to ask you what's
your view and how the government's
responding are we likely to see a much
wider Crackdown by the security forces
against the demonstrators as these
protests gain traction
right my my view is that this government
has
um failed to grasp the severity
um and the depth of the political crisis
in Peru president boluarte herself as
well as many of her ministers have
repeatedly dismissed the protesters as
the work of either professional
agitators or violent groups or even
terrorist groups with the name of
discrediting them and justifying
repression against them they are
unwilling to in fact today
um the Press reported that after she
learned about the death of the first
protester
president bolivarte said they are
protesting against what we do not
understand what they are asking for what
you are asking for is a pretext to
continue generating chaos so she's
completely dismissing the protests and
failing to understand the the depth of
the crisis let's stay with those demands
for a second um Joe Marie because the
protesters are calling for the
resignation of the new president Dina
boloati and early elections is the
government likely to make any
concessions any compromises to try and
resolve this crisis do you think
um I think it's very difficult she has
dug in her heels she is supported by the
right wing uh caucus in the Congress
which is also dug in its heels and I
think that they believe that with a
little bit more repression they can
bring an end to the protest and continue
governing the country and recurring
power so I'm worried
in this context yes just just to broaden
things out and uh and get a final
thought from you uh Joe Marie I mean how
are South American leaders viewing the
political unrest in Peru and do you
think the International Community has a
role to play here should they be
stepping up and putting much more
pressure uh on boloati's government to
resolve this crisis
well to be fair
um
the inter-american commission commission
for human rights sent to Mission in
December sending another
to arrive the day after tomorrow
um the uh the United Nations is also
sending a mission not as high level
emission as I'd like but they're still
sending a mission so international human
rights entities have taken note of the
human rights crisis and the broader
political crisis
um but for example the U.S government
has stood very firmly by the bolo Arte
Administration and has not made any
comment about the growing crisis about
the repression about the killing of
civilians
um and there's been a more mixed uh
response by other governments in the
region I think Jeremy Ebert really good
to get your thoughts thank you very much
indeed for talking about azira thank you
thank you for having me